alright that was the Ubisoft press
conference right here at e3 2015 let's
start talking about what we saw right at
the end it looks like ghost recons back
for the first time in a long time since
advanced warfighter two with Ghost Recon
wildlands go ahead ghost recon you know
on online yes I so what each assault
ribs yeah oh yeah future soldiers well
it always had a few actually my
apologies what do you think about why
Lance from what we saw it's from just
fresh off so this is their Just Cause II
we were we were saying while we were
watching it looked a bit far right it
had like a touch of watch dogs with the
end the very idea I'm saying quite quite
as almost like mercenaries co-op having
a little bit yeah it was very explodey
yeah in that sense so we know so far I
guess is that this is an open-world
co-op game but with specific missions as
well yeah this drug lab set up here was
what they sort of focused on um Alexa
any thoughts on what we've seen here in
terms of like what this might be in
terms of a grander game because all the
showing here I guess as a bunch of dudes
going in to shoot a bunch of other dudes
like how do you have how do you think
this looks differently to other yeah
Ubisoft shooters ah I don't think it
does like I'm seeing far cry I'm seeing
um like some watchdog elements i think
it's sort of an amalgam of everything
that they've been exploring with other
with other franchises i mean that can
work that's super cool when they got to
this part i started thinking it might
have been call of juarez yeah there's a
couple of people like twitter saying the
same thing as well lucio your
impressions of this i think first of all
got to celebrate the fact that this was
a genuine surprise yeah true i mean
they've kept this really under wraps
Anubis after not really known for
keeping the ship this ship watertight um
so I'm kind of yeah I'm excited to see
more of it it was weird though I
expected more of a fanfare it is a new
game but we just got this trailer so I'm
excited about seeing it I assume they're
gonna have at least this trailer or some
representative on the booth to talk
about it yeah you'd hope so it looks
cool I'm also card or woman yeah the
Roman good point that's a
nology spread across all of that
Ubisoft's various teams and it's kind of
an inch in take I think Kevin I'm kind
of I like the fact that this is I don't
know the the co-op stuff in FarCry 4 was
good fun the idea of expanding that add
almost like the crew where you've got
this mat open world you can team up with
a couple of buddies and I don't take on
mission right all around the place I'm
pretty excited but yeah I mean I think
it's gonna be super fun I mean I think
the downside of course is that it does
remind us of all of the other ubisoft
game yeah we looked at it and think hey
it looks like is this could this be far
cry maybe um and I think that's the only
the only real drawback at the the
specific might have been a surprise but
what this game is I don't think is
actually a surprise at all yeah whether
that doesn't mean it's not going to be
awesome more fun but I don't think that
it makes for much of a surprise yeah
it's crazy to think like how far removed
this is from the original title of ghost
recon as well it's kind of its it the
things they've done with this franchise
been kind of all over the place a head
tattoo yeah the head said that might be
my next I'll two don't match you never
know crosses tattooed on her face I feel
like that's something all of our mothers
who told us at some stage you're not and
that's Ghost Recon wildlands that's all
we know about it so far that's our
initial and probably literally saw it
like three minutes ago as your fingers
cause to be more information about that
and we'll have it right here on gamespot
com all right next up to talk about we
got a bunch of games to get through here
folks and I want to talk about the
division next we've seen the division at
ubisoft conference a couple years in a
row here this is the third year they've
had a big fanfare aranda is it just me
or does this game look not really as
pretty as it did a couple of years are
you going down the watchdog's room I
don't say like this downgrade nonsense
but like man like the dip Ghost Recon
trailer looked better than what I saw
from the division well we'll come back
to that in two years time see ya don't
know it's i'm happy about today's game
play because it finally showed off the
sort of online connectability what it
means to be playing this game with a
bunch of people and running into other
people yeah also that ryan guy god what
the end of the demo
so in their thing is I mean we've seen a
lot of these multiplayer places on the
press conferences but no one's really
acting like they would in a real
multipla situation apart from that guy
griefs everyone at the end and so what
we saw in the demo was the the the sort
of the main human team here we're
following three characters going around
basically doing a mission in the in the
world of the division get accosted by
this other group of bad online players
and then he sort of band together and
then at the end they decide to turn on
them and then on the end it turns out
the one of their friends decided to turn
on them as well so they really lose
interesting to me I mean other games
that a kane and lynch is the first game
that comes to mind that's done this
before but what's interesting about that
is in kane and lynch had always just
devolved into everybody's just going to
betray everybody else in whatever and so
my mic my first question would be what's
to keep that from being a thing that you
do what you thinking that you know it
sounds like a good idea but in practice
is it really going to be meaningful or
is it always just going to end up being
the same anyway yeah I'm really curious
about that yeah it's got good to see
them show off a little bit more of the
connectability stuff but still it's it's
almost that thing we're so intrigued by
that there are as many questions that
get answered we get our loads more
questions like for instance why do you
leave a Christmas tree lit up when
electricity seems to have gone out in
most of the city because you know the
spirit of Christmas lives on done
because sometimes you need a good shot
and sometimes the shot overrides logic
in film and in Game the point I see this
is the crow essential moment where I
he's like no I'm not gonna help you uh
pro- you off because this is internet
video games look God look at the numbers
guns him down yeah right their stuff
kind of just looks at them stairs him in
the ILO but we also got a date for the
division and March 8 2016 we can look
forward to not slipping probably one
more time before Ellie's wants cynics
all of us cynics I'm really excited for
a division I like it on paper I like the
idea of the interconnected multiplayer
the idea of being in groups I'm a little
bit down on the graphic stuff final
thoughts on the division Alexa what
you think I don't know I'm sort of I
feel like there are so many military
shooters or military s cuter yeah a
newbie stop speaking all of them yeah I
don't know I some still I still don't
think I've seen anything different other
than I guess the ability to turn on your
team yeah and take their stuff no but
you think loose you know I could've lied
like the idea um it kinda reminded me a
little bit of I am Alive yuba so yeah
fabled other post-apocalyptic game
worried just had that kind of feeling
you know when the two groups kind of
came up against each other and you're
like two or trust him door not my mail
didn't matter yeah I mean that game
could have been so much so much more but
maybe some of the ideas went into a
Division I don't know why it looks I'd
I'm still cautious than too excited mmm
Kevin final thoughts yeah it's still
same pretty much cautiously optimistic
about it perhaps because i want the
Destiny asked to be a burgeoning genre
of its own that's worthy of getting
attention and this is the one game right
now that seems to be really following in
those footsteps and I really want a
better type of Destiny game so maybe
this will be it maybe not maybe 2016 is
the year of that sort of maybe there's
more more of these games at coming after
ya destiny to come on at e3 2016 what
we've been playing at the division by
the time that comes out March 8th 2016
is when hopefully as long as doesn't
slip will all be playing the division
and if you want any updates on that game
of course stay tuned right here to
gamespot com all right we got a bunch
more games to talk about how about
Assassin's Creed syndicate we saw some
more Assassin's Creed syndicate snowy
didn't know so see ya tri-level we saw
cgi trailer which which looks almost as
close to gameplay that I feel like I'm
being cheated when I watch it because it
kind of looks like a copyright that good
but it doesn't and Kevin what are your
thoughts on sendagaya I'm sort of iffy
at this point just because they oh they
always know how to pick a good song for
a trailer so plus there um but it's it's
just a sass and Crete and I can't
believe I've got this thing on my arm
and I'm saying this hey know those
frames are real good they were with that
but I don't know like I'm at the stage
where I'm just like I needed to see more
there was nothing more of Assassin's
Creed I mean they're all there will be
more at the show there
it'll be playable and that kind of thing
I think but I don't know just that in
and of itself plus this is really
nitpicky but if somebody who's played so
much Assassin's Creed the lighting and
the colors are sort of bothering me yeah
because the trailer sort of had some of
the same that the yellow has just been
cranked up so high good lighting and
dissipated driving me insane and we saw
that in the the gameplay footage that
they also showed that the yellow has
been cranked up so high it's like I find
it so much better obviously because it's
CG but just even in terms of the style I
just prefer this so much better
something about the lighting and the
gameplay we've seen that really irks me
and I just all of this could it looks
close enough to gameplay yeah just a
little bit jarring I mean if you're
gonna kill some horses you might as well
don't god I hated this and at least they
might as well be English yeah I mean
what good is it yeah facebook or
original here's to that car equine leap
of faith yeah yeah this is a renowned
for being really able to take full take
a fall on the face alexia we're looking
forward to seeing the other protagonist
of this trailer as well and they didn't
do it no I'm disappointed because we've
seen two bits of gameplay and trailers
now and they keep saying oh this is gate
this game is about Jacob and Evie Frye
and they talk about the twins and how
they're both important but we now have
two very lengthy CGI trailers just focus
focusing on this male protagonist and
it's doubly disappointing because it
Bethesda yesterday we got two trailers
with that you can play as a man or women
and they had the dishonored here the
option to play as either and they chose
to focus on Emily I wonder if this is
their PR team deciding that they're
going to leave all that stuff till the
last yeah our just for six months
showing him off last six months showing
her off we'll have to wait and see but
it did seem a little bit weird because
they've been teasing her for so long to
then spend six minutes showing off this
dude again the whiskey just looks like a
British Ezio kind of a jerk facial hair
looks dumb yeah I mean it's already
beloved alright I guess we'll have to
wait and see any other thoughts on on
this bubbly see you know I mean we're
gonna be seeing it on the game spot
stage actually check out where we're
gonna have hopefully actual gameplay so
I'm excited to see that so I mean yeah
it's Assassin's Creed I'll play it I
know I will
no point saying that i won't i want to
get real excited for Assassin's Creed
game I know right right yeah like I
don't I think all four of us are people
who enjoy sasses Creed but it's just
yeah it's not how get hyped up right now
about half the third and that's coming
at this counter year so fingers crossed
we'll see some more and fingers crossed
we'll have some more coverage as well in
the game spot stage so make sure you
stay tuned against what com for more of
that alright let's do a quick little
roundup of everything else we saw first
off TrackMania turbo no one expected
that Oh hands up if you like trackmania
yeah you know it like it looked fun
anything they said they had a VR demo
yes good thing I'll actually get sick on
V or I feel like that might be the
quickest way to get sick on view I just
need to vomit yeah yeah oh just thinking
of it now makes me think oh my oh it was
a game called toy box turbos which very
similar premise and they did it in via
but they did it you know the camera
pulled way back and kind of following
along and that didn't a kind of word
created it was gonna going from third
person to fertilize it and there you
have it around so fast this really looks
like trackmania nations which was a
cobble live it's about maybe four years
old going there before all that maybe a
planet nonsense so we don't know if
they're actually going to keep with
mania planet that was when they beliefs
trackmania and they had like you did you
got like are you get to buy stadium and
you to buy all your different like areas
and this one they say there's going to
be four environments off the track 200
tracks they also have their sort of
procedurally generated track thing as
well variety of cars as well it's kind
of like f1 v8 looking things there and
some other type of dirt cars yeah and
also a virtual reality mmm they go and a
bitchin hat yeah and I'm sweet yep truck
manis back in a big way and for a second
air it also looked like we had some sort
of my god [ __ ] what was that like I
can on it so with every mcgeorge ciders
it's dark centers and it's a cat riding
a fire-breathing unicorn the double
rainbow in the background like oh of
course it's Charles few trials fusions
expansion back now go it was like his
rod so this is like the blood dragon for
trials right yeah trials at this an
expansion pack were you what is your
caste riding a unicorn with it
everything that we're all
so funny like I'm so mo ng what welcome
to the future and then lay knows
anything is my just let this speak for
itself yeah well triple rainbow the
whole bunch of knots is gonna this is
awesome level max which is the expansion
coming soon for phantom trials fusion
add there was new add-on game is an
allure I know to a widget to 2050 yeah
so what was last 120 70 70 yeah so
they're going so mature again on future
again you decide with a moon I did play
this is that I can't get into specifics
until tomorrow but we know that it
exists now and so yeah the moon and it's
a city builder and there's a whole I
mean if you've played the anima series
where you sort of know what you're
getting into and so you know a trade
game you know a game where you build
city and you're trading to make your
citizens more and more happy and to
expand and stuff like that but with the
moon yeah and I guess to be more on that
on gamespot tomorrow Kevin yeah totally
sweet and moving swiftly on who knew
they had some dancing happening JC just
turned up that was like do you remember
when I'm sure paid the microsoft press
conference I forget there he is there it
is do it yeah whatever you're no Prince
Jason and this is coming in on a bunch
of platforms they're also bringing it
just dance unlimited on ps4 xbox one and
Wii U I think they also have them they
also said you can play with your phone
now great which I said that last year
yeah don't even need a console Johnny
well the best is deployed to dance with
my phone yeah when people look at me
while I'm dancing looking at my phone oh
man plaintiff or game while they're
dancing up I mean I mean nothing like
this not much you can say about just
danica yeah yeah this is the game of
what you dance now let's stretch let's
keep going let's keep five minutes I'm
just Oh hundred fifty of the greatest
just dance hits new songs all of our
teen Gangnam style all right recognized
yeah oh good but I think the best
presentation I know we like to jason to
dilute the river how about an actual
Viking coming out on stage like a game
that guy for honor that looks awesome
beard guy is the best guy that ever
guide in the history know your
of a beard guy yeah the beard guy was
the best guy and he is the Dark Lord yes
on Twitter underscore Dark Lord Lord
with an e oh I'd like to point out so
he's the underscore dark lordy so you
should follow this dude because he's
frightening and great Kimbo that beard
guy evangelist what did you think of for
honor I want that combat an assassin's
creed why can't we have that look like
Shiva it looks like chivalry but does it
have mobile elements cuz it looked like
there was stuff going on in the
background like maybe this is yeah like
I was kind of thinking do I rira furring
to those mobiles cuz like titanfall does
that we don't say that's a MOBA oh yeah
I mean I know it's hard to tell hmm I
thought maybe there were creeps and
there were like you know like territory
to control I guess move further towards
the yeah the enemy camp but i don't know
i could be just making this [ __ ] up so i
go looks wrong that's kind of what i'm
doing actually and at the last game to
talk about south park the fractured
bought whole oh gotcha what naming
butthole they really want a 9.5 on games
I don't know the hard to tell them we
don't even have 9.5 anymore but I'll go
with it he'll go with it at Trey and
mass back on stage doing it again this
time obsidian not involved ubi sub San
Francisco apparently ah not really a
surprise yeah I'm not surprised either
why an obsidian isn't is it isn't is a
good good developer but they do other
things hmm I think better than what they
did with with South Park okay yeah i
loved stick of truth but i thought it
was a little too like formula or simple
it was a little too formulaic it was
simple easy fibrin and hilarious and
awesome and there was so much more to do
with it um i like the game but i think
that made that maybe this is an
opportunity for ubisoft enough to really
push the boundaries there well I also
think obsidian moves to new things
pretty quickly they don't really stick
with something well that's all that
Ubisoft have to show for us we're going
to take a quick little break and we will
be back right here on that the game spot
I guess war room stage Sony's kicking
off in just a little bit of times we're
going to start our pre-show for that so
stay tuned and
we'll be back girl woods